hi in this video we would learn about
maturation promoting factor or MPF
nowadays we know that MPF is nothing but
a complex of cycling B and cdk1 together
it works like a phosphoric
phosphorylation enzyme so it
phosphorylate several downstream targets
and cdk1 is setting 309 kinase and its
activity is modulated by cycling be
cycling B is specially important at the
mitotic phase of the cell division and
its expression level or its
concentration also increases at that
particular point of time so in this
video first we'll look at how cycling B
and C D K 1 that means the maturation
promoting factor was discovered that
would help us to understand that how
this complex is actually helping in the
cell cycle everything started in 1970 in
1970 John gay heart was working on Z
nobis now the scene opus has their
distinct size eggs or asides now he
isolated the z nobis o sites and when
the Z no pass a site which were arrested
in g2 in an immature state was injected
with progesterone what happens is it
really match yours too meiosis 2 a
metaphase blocked o site ready to be
fertilized so this process is known as
the oocyte maturation so some substance
such as progesterone lead to a side
maturation and this is true mostly
progesterone help in maturation of the
oocyte right now they wondered that what
molecular level changes is occurring
while protester on is injected
in order to understand that the
hypothesize that something soluble in
the cytoplasm was changing so they
injected the Frog with progesterone and
then took out its mature GU sites from
the mature oocyte they took out the
cytoplasm or did a cytoplasmic extract
they were biochemist so they were always
interested about extracts and everything
and using the micro injection based
experiment they injected it into an to
match your arrested ooh site in g2 and
what happened was amazing the oocyte
which was immature and was sitting in g2
phase after injection with the
cytoplasmic extract from a mature oocyte
it quickly matures that suggests that
some soluble substances present in the
cytoplasm that leads to the maturation
of the Oh site and that is why they
named this mr. mysterious substance as
maturation promoting factor it leads to
maturation of the sites it's also known
as mitosis promoting factor as well so
this factor between one wanted to
understand that which phase of the cell
cycle these factor is important and its
concentration is high now clearly they
have an assay they can take the
cytoplasmic extract from a cell at any
point of time and inject it into the
oocyte which is arrested in g2 a mature
oocyte and the SAV doubt if the oocyte
is matured then the MPF activity is
present a simple but elegant enough
biochemical assay using this assay they
figure out
I mean before they figure out they were
there are like couple of questions that
what is the soluble substance what is
the common chemical nature of this
soluble substance but the asset that I
was talking about the free route that
the MPF activity was elevated during
meow
this one meiosis to the first mitotic
division and the second mitotic division
so while the cell is dividing just
before that the activity of the MPF is
really increasing still it does not
solve the problem what is the chemical
nature of these soluble substance which
is known as MPF by the same time Tim
Hunt was working with sea urchin embryos
now in sea urchin embryos they are
pretty much big and it is really easy to
track their diffusion and that is why
what he was doing was completely
different nothing to aim to discover the
MPF he was studying parthenogenesis but
however he did one experiment after
fertilization he wanted to look at the
cell division kinetics and that is why
he took out sample at regular interval
and ran that in a GL when the gel was
developed and that time it was
radioactive development of those gels he
found that there are a lot of proteins
but sub proteins are consistent
throughout the cell cycle though there
are little fluctuation in the levels but
they're consistent throughout the cell
cycle for example in this particular
plot the protein bands marked by Y and
said they reliably appear in all phases
of the cell cycle and all time points
strikingly enough one or two lanes he
saw that some proteins increases
gradually and then just before the
division just before the silicified
there level drops and he tried to
quantify it in terms of the band
intensity and some sort of craft is
obtained like this this thing if he
superimposed with the cell division time
it just looks like this just before the
cell division cell is about to divide
the protein is degraded a little bit
time before the sale is about pretty
white its activity was pretty
hi this graph has a striking similarity
with the graph of MPF activity does that
mean that MPF is actually this
mysterious substance which is cycling in
a particular interval he named this
substance as cycling because it has a
cyclic appearance and disappearance that
is why he would named it cycling now
what happened is in from the safe sea
urchin embryos
he took out our purified this cycling be
using : purification because that's a
golden era of biochemistry not only that
cycling BC DNA was cloned after that
using that same cDNA as in opus cDNA
library was scanned and hybridization
experiments confirmed that indeed there
is a homolog of cycling be present in
sin opus question is what it is doing
and how it is related with the MPF now
in e.coli the cDNA of the Zeno passu
site was cloned and a protein was bulk
purified then it was actually injected
in mice to perform hybridoma and perform
a mock monoclonal antibody using that
monoclonal antibody they acid and look
it looks like this monoclonal antibody
which is specific to cyclin b actually
detected some substances inside the
xenoka school side from the purified MPF
activity from the purified fraction word
people find the MPF activity it also
gets detected by this specific antibody
indeed this experiment suggested that
cyclin b is actually a component of
maturation promoting factor that was
amazing at that point when experiments
from two completely different model
organism done by
two completely different type of
scientists a cell biologist and a
biochemist together lead to the
discovery of this amazing molecule
cyclin b which is a component of
maturation promoting factor the other
component of the maturation promoting
factor which is silica one was actually
discovered by a geneticist in East so
completely three different model
organism lead to explanation of a
biological phenomena now we know this
maturation promoting factor is so
important on in the onset of prophase in
onset of growth phase maturation
promoting factor phosphorylates nuclear
pore subunits which leads to their
dissociation not only that lamins
which are actually its support to the
nuclear envelope is actually
phosphorylated Lamine is a in
intermediate filament which has three
important domain and in the main domain
the lamin is phosphorylated by cycling p
which leads to dissociation of the
lambing filaments from each other once
lamine is collapsed the nuclear membrane
also collapse and that's a key event in
the prophase right which is triggered by
maturation promoting factor not only
that maturation promoting factors level
started rising after S phase and it
really peaks at the end of g2 and
mitotic phase right at this point of
time
maturation promoting factor is also
important to prevent the re-entry into a
replication state so replication happens
only one time in the cell cycle now but
it turns out the origin of replication
complex is bound all the time how this
is triggered then it turns out some
triggering factor such as cg d1 and c d
c6 are phosphorylated and in this
phosphorylated state they cannot
reattach to the over C and maturation
promoting factor actually maintain this
phosphorylated state and as a result
maturation from Orting factor can
prevent these triggering factor to bind
to or cnv initiate replication
but at that but what happens is like at
our Lee Jiwon phase these maturation
promoting factor is degraded by ubiquity
knowledge and and proteasome mediated
lysis then what happens several
phosphorylase or deep or phosphatase
enzyme can come and d phosphorylate
these triggering factor that is why in S
phase assembly of these triggering
factor can take place in the origin of
replication and the origin can fire and
start a new round of replication in the
S phase that is how the strict balance
between phosphorus phosphorylation and
dephosphorylation and phosphorylation by
cycling B cdk1 complex ensures that
replication is restricted to a specific
time window so in this video we not only
looked at how the discovery of MPF took
place we also looked at how MPF works in
several phase of cell cycle and helps in
cell division so I hope you enjoyed this
video if you liked this video give me a
quick thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe thank you